there are people who seem to be upset
that there are rabbis asking for
ceasefire it's bizarre because you would
assume that if you are a religious
leader if you are a faith leader that
your number one priority would be to
look into your faith into the teachings
of your faith and to say I oppose
violence she's absolutely vile and a
Hamas apologist also I don't know that
these are actual rabbis standing behind
could you talk a little bit about her
commentary whilst we do believe in peace
we also truly and totally believe in as
a commandment in the ability to defend
ourselves against any enemy that comes
to kill us the lack of education is just
totally and completely obvious so to go
ahead and pretend like the rabbis of the
world are out there you know calling for
a ceasefire which is really a different
way of saying allowing Kamas to kill
more Israelis is just it's just bizarre
and it's stupid